everybody wants to go on holiday and get
back to normal as quickly as possible
but this is reckless we know that the
Delta variant came into this country and
delayed the lifting of some of the
restrictions and caused infections here
we need to make sure that we've got
proper data-driven analysis and that we
look at an international passport for
vaccines and we also know that people
who have had the vaccine of course can
still get the virus so a testing regime
is very important and crucial as well so
I'm very concerned about the
government's announcements by the press
this morning okay which particular part
of it is reckless do you feel because a
lot of Brits want to go on holiday
they've been double jabbed get a week in
the sun after the last 18 months come
back and not and be able to go back to
work rather than having to self-isolate
sure and I completely understand
people's position on that and of course
we want to be able to facilitate that as
quickly as possible but like I say we
know that the vaccine passport isn't an
internationally recognized one we don't
know the circumstances of how that's
going to be administrated and of course
people can still carry mutations and
different levels of the virus so
therefore we believe that at the moment
the government haven't done enough to
make sure that we Safeguard our borders
and we haven't got an internationally
recognized vaccine passport which is
what the government said that they was
working towards so it does feel Reckless
especially when we saw the Delta variant
coming in this country yeah but um
looking at I mean if you're double
jabbed and then the Fortnight afterwards
you are 10 according to the latest
figures just out today you're 10 times
less likely to die from uh covid than
you would be if you had not been
vaccinated at some stage we have to
learn to live with this virus sure and
the vaccine program has been a huge
success and you know the Oxford trials
and everything that we're able to
achieve in this country has been amazing
but actually you can still get the virus
you can still get long covered and it's
so important that we know where the
virus is and whether it mutates or not
so testing is a really important part of
that tool but do you acknowledge that we
will have to live with kobit at some
stage we will have to accept that it is
is within our communities forever yeah
and we're already living with the virus
at the moment and that's why a testing
regime is really crucial about that
because we know the virus will continue
to be prevalent across the UK and
globally but we have to keep an eye on
mutations because the vaccine at the
moment has held up against any of the
mutations but we know what that can do
to our economy if we do get outbreaks of
infections and it causes more problems
in the UK from the 16th of August that's
the date that the government is giving
us date a date and updates is what they
often say that little phrase
um if you've been pinged if you've come
into contact with somebody you've had
who's had covered and you're double jab
then you're still going to be able to go
to work some unions are not happy with
that yeah and we believe that actually
you know we've seen now the virus we
know what the virus is like we've got
more information about that so that's
why testing and ventilation in
workplaces and in our schools is really
important as well so we've said that the
government needs to follow the medical
guidance and the advice and the
scientists and we also need to make sure
sure that that testing regime is there
for people it's free when they need it
and that's a crucial part of dealing
with this virus as well as having those
vaccines so Labor's view is even after
the 16th of August if workers are not
comfortable going into work they feel
anxious about it then they shouldn't
have to now employers should work with
employees and that's what's been
happening across the UK actually and
most of employees have been going into
work and have been supporting that of
course the sage advice has been that
where people can work from home that
that should be possible and again today
I'm announcing around flexible working
that's not just about working from home
but looking at compressed hours as well
so that people can have a real balance
between their family life and their work
life so more people will be able to come
back into the workplace and more people
will be able to work in a flexible way
that will help businesses as well as
help their family so do you think that
covid has changed the landscape and that
we will find some workers not having to
go into the office again I think covert
has changed the landscape that's pretty
clear and what we we've announced today
and what we're saying is that actually
we need to think about that I think
before there was a hesitation from
employers thinking that productivity
would be low or it would be too
strenuous for them to look at working in
different flexible ways but we've seen
that they've been able to do that and
employees have stepped up to the plate
and they've done that as well so now
we're saying well actually why don't we
look at flexible working and having
different compressed hours that work
around your child care that work around
your family lives that will enable more
people to go back into the workplace
into their skilled employment that they
may have and give a good work-life
balance to people which of course is
incredibly important to people and we've
seen that through this pandemic the
importance of family the importance of
friends and being able to be part of
that as well as work
so just to clarify you do envisage your
situation where some people will not go
into the office again they may not and
you know some people may work from home
and of course some people have already
been doing that that a lot of people
work from home anyway and have their
businesses from home so that's always
been a practice but what we want to see
is more flexibility for people
regardless of what occupation they're in
if they're able to work flexibly then we
think employers should work with them to
enable that to happen
um Michael Grove said that people who
don't have
um the vaccination double jabbed are
selfish do you think they are no there's
some people that can't have the
vaccination for medical reasons and
therefore they're not selfish and that
actually what we've done and what we've
seen is an encouragement of people to
get the vaccine and people have stepped
up to that you know we've seen that
there's been cues for the vaccine and
that's absolutely brilliant and
tremendous we should do that we should
do that for students get these vaccine
um
situations on campus so that people can
get access to the vaccine as quickly as
possible but we know from the medical
advice is that compulsory vaccination is
not the way to go it's giving people the
information and encouragement to take up
the vaccine and where we've done that
we've been incredibly successful how
does it help when politicians describe
people as selfish if they don't have a
vaccine I don't think it's helpful
because people who have taken the
decision not to get the vaccine for
quite legitimate reasons will be sat
there feeling very upset that people
think that they're selfish people are
not selfish what we want to see is
testing so we can see where the virus is
so that we can isolate it but
encouragement for people to take up the
vaccine which as you say is you know
made sure that people are not dying in
the numbers that we saw at the beginning
and that the people can get back to as
an ordinary life as possible so how
would you describe people who for no
other reason than they just don't fancy
it how would you describe those people
who don't want to have a vaccine I don't
think there's many people like that that
just don't want it but there may be some
that are like that and that's a person
and that's a personal choice to them you
know if you decide to have a vaccine put
into your body of course we have lots of
vaccines for different things at the
moment and that's a personal choice to
them I don't think it's selfish what
politicians should be doing and what I'm
doing is encouraging people to speak to
their doctor if they've got concerns
about the vaccine get the right
information not stuff online that may be
not factually correct but actually speak
to your GP speak to the medical experts
and get the vaccine I got the vaccine I
thought it was safe for me and that was
a personal choice but I don't think I
should be then preaching to other people
about what choices are it is the wrong
decision if you choose not to have a
vaccine for no other reason than you
either don't you know you don't want to
do it for whatever reason that might be
that is not
um that is not presumably what your
party would stand for because you want
all of us to look after each other
that's the social thing to do it is and
we're of course encouraging people to
take the vaccine but even after you've
had the vaccine you can still get the
virus it's not 100
um you know immunity to the virus so
that's why we're saying testing is an
important part of that and of course
making sure that if you're in an
occupational workplace that you have the
appropriate equipment to keep you safe
that this ventilation where possible and
the government have failed to do enough
on that you know we've got the scores
going back in September we should be
putting proper ventilation into those
schools so that we can follow the sage
advice and make sure that we're doing
everything we possibly can to keep
control of the virus uh what's Labor
doing to honor victims of the child sex
abuse of care home residents from the
60s to the 90s in London it's absolutely
appalling that what we've seen in
Lambeth over that period and the
children that suffered so badly over
that period is absolutely heartbreaking
the most things that we need to do is
first of all recognize the failures that
happened over you know decades in
Lambeth and then learn from those
mistakes we've seen this in other parts
of the country and that actually have to
recognize where this predatory behavior
has happened and where people are in
positions of authority have failed those
young people so badly and you know my I
feel so strongly about this because
often often it's vulnerable people from
backgrounds like my own that have been
put into situations where they should
have been kept safe and the system has
completely failed them we have to learn
the lessons of that and part of that is
recognizing where we did things wrong
and then making sure that that can never
happen again before I let you go John
Butler um thrown out of the uh chamber
for saying that the Prime Minister was a
liar we had Annie McDonald on from your
party yesterday saying what he is a liar
I put that to the work and pension
secretary this morning she said he's
more popular than your leader
well I mean I just think that you know
Don Butler was correct and it's it's
absolutely ludicrous that if somebody's
lied especially the prime minister of
this country that you can't call that
out in Parliament it's our uh archaic
way of doing things in Parliament but if
somebody's lied I think you should be
able to if you could back that up and
show that that person has lied then we
should be able to say that and that but
it was quite right to say that why then
do you think he's more popular than your
leader why do you think he's the Prime
Minister well British people trust him
more than they trust your leader well I
think that care is doing a fantastic job
as being the leader of the opposition
it's been difficult times but I actually
do think that we're going ahead now
we're showing people that we're a
government in waiting like the policy
that I've announced today around
flexible working this government is
running out of tract and on their lies
their corruption and their and their
Bluster we've seen this Bluster you know
you can't keep blustering forever there
has to come a point where you actually
do what you say and that's not what the
government have been doing so I think
there's going to be a Day of Reckoning
for Boris it's great to see you thanks
for coming in thank you really
appreciate it thank you